hey guys this is a quick public service
announcement before my interview with
david horowitz you know david horowitz
actually said a couple lines that we are
being forced to censor because of the
youtube rules we have never done
something like this before and as far as
i know david horowitz is a free citizen
in the free country of the united states
who is entitled to free speech that
being said i can't risk having this
channel deleted from youtube and that
basically is what would happen if we
went ahead and aired it unedited so you
will hear some bleeps in this interview
if you would like to hear what david
horowitz a free man in a free country
actually said you can check out the full
video at
rubinreport.locals.com and quick shout
out to susan wojecki over at youtube
people go along with the crowd it's
survival
it's very when i was 35 and left the
left i lost every friend that i had in
life uh and i had to start all over
again and
when that happened it seemed impossible
but i've had a good life afterwards so
it's possible but i think most people
are just afraid of losing their friends
that's pretty much and that's why the
left is so vicious
in the way it characterizes its
opponents
and uh you know
because of that it keeps everybody in
line they don't want to be called racist
and
white supremacist and all that
i'm dave rubin and joining me is the
original why i left the left guy as well
as the author of around 20 books i
couldn't even figure out how many
including his most recent the enemy
within how a totalitarian movement is
destroying america david horowitz
welcome back to the reuben report thanks
for having me dave i'm glad to have you
back on so first off you've written at
least 20 books i mean do you even know
at this point
no
i actually don't
but it's like that i've been like four
in the last two years
yeah you you are a prolific writer i
have many of your books on my shelf uh
but let's quickly before we get into the
new book and you've predicted i mean you
really have been right about so much and
i i wonder if that makes you feel good
or or depressed but before i do anything
else you sort of are the original why i
left the left guy for people that
haven't seen our original interview
we'll link to it down below but you sort
of 30 years before me made that move
uh i suspect you feel pretty good about
it after coming from a family that was
communist and socialist and being a
lefty and then finally reagan broke you
and here you are
it's hard to feel good about being right
about such terrible things that have
happened to our country
yeah i was raised by communists i was
the editor of the largest magazine of
the new left
um
and i left the left what i realized as
you did eventually
that it's not about peace and justice
it's a hate america left these people
are
they're totalitarians they want to
control every aspect of your life down
to the pronouns
um
and that makes them very very dangerous
it's a it's a crypto religion as i've
said for a long time
they believe in a redemption but they
think the redeemers can be politicians
please
there's never a world that's just
because it's made up of people who are
the problem
that's a that's the perception of jenna
the whole our whole saga is told in
genesis in the bible
had paradise was better than the green
new deal
but there was only one thing you had to
do to stay in paradise and that was not
to want to do evil
and i
it's mind-boggling to me because of the
you have all these live television these
television shows about murders
about how terrible people are
if they just showed you the cruelty to
animals that people are capable of you
could never believe
in a world redeemed
by radicals or any any mortals
yeah well i i suspect that the mortals
on the cover of this book are are not
the mortals that you think are going to
get us to redemption i mean this is a uh
this is pretty pretty much all of the
bad guys uh right here
what
that's the favorite part of my
contribution to the book i designed that
cover yeah
there you go you design the cover with
the head shots with the head shots of
some radicals do you do you believe is
it your position that they all are
equally radical like is is the ill han
omar say aoc
ayanna presley thing or rashida talib
thing is that as is that more radical
than say pelosi schumer biden or is it
all just the same thing at this point
thing in the left and that is that very
there are very few serious people
um
we're living on so much misinformation
and ignorance
so i i think you know people go along
with the crowd it's survival
it's very when i was 35 and left the
left i lost every friend that i had in
life
uh and i had to start all over again and
when that happened it seemed impossible
but i've had a good life afterwards so
it's possible but i think most people
are just afraid of losing their friends
that's
pretty much and that's why the left is
so vicious
in the way it characterizes its
opponents
and uh you know
because of that it keeps everybody in
line they don't want to be called racist
and
white supremacist and all that
um
i think we're
the sad reality is that we're in the
early stages of a
fascist state and i use that word
advisedly
if you think of the
i just lost a friend of 70 years ron
radasha wrote a story about it
because i questioned
the election results in 2020 i lose a
friend of 70 years
when there's all these irregularities
that are obvious and when nobody has
done an audit of the election
and when the democrats have challenged
every republican presidential victory
since 2000 2000 2004 of course the trump
election
and then if you look what happened on
january 6 this is the great crime of
conservatives
first of all
trump's speech
basically he said not basically
literally in so many words he said i
want you to
protest peacefully and patriotically i
want you to
stiffen the spines of weak republicans
who are afraid to challenge
this
election result and if you fail he said
then what you must do is go home and
primary them you can imagine a more
democratic
peaceful
statement than that
okay so those people went and for
whatever reason some of them got out of
control
and the crime they've been charged
actually charged with
is trespassing
there are people who are still in jail
it's now five months
held out bail
for trespassing and what was the
democrats reaction they called it an
armed insurrection even though there was
not a single armed confiscator zero zero
it was it was actually a fairly peaceful
protest when you think about everything
that happened all summer with democrat
support they didn't the capital they
didn't destroy a lot of things
and the only person who was murdered or
was killed
was a trump supporter
and her murderer
is protected by pelosi we still don't
know his name and he's not they're not
going to be any charges
and it was videoed by a journalist who's
showing
that she was completely non-threatening
she was unarmed she's small and she was
threatening nobody
when she was killed
that journalist a hispanic is in jail
for being there and being a journalist
if this isn't fascism
i don't know what it is but it's worse
than that because policy
remember she said republicans are
enemies of the state
i remember the the democrats the leftist
and the far left in the democratic which
is pretty dominant caucus and the
democrat party
called for the expulsion actually of a
hundred republicans from the house for
questioning the election
josh hawley and ted cruz were singled
out by the democrat leadership to be
removed from the senate because they
questioned an election when the
democrats have done this every election
in recent memory hillary clinton still
has a tweet up right now about the
illegitimate presidency of donald trump
yeah exactly they never accepted trump
uh yet
this is supposed to be a threat to our
democracy that you raise
and anybody who's looked at the evidence
knows that there was humongous
irregularities to put a nice term on it
during the election
um but then nancy pelosi orders 25 000
troops into the capital at a cost of
half a billion dollars
for
non-existent non-specified threat
what is that but to send a message to
conservatives that they're gunning for
us
then the head of the military orders a
two-month stand down to conduct a
witch-hunt of so-called extremists
in the military than in the capitol
police than in homeland security then
the justice department announces there's
there's going to allocate 89 million
dollars
to investigate extremists i'm meaning
conservatives all over the country
it's so reminiscent of the reichstag
fire
hitler was elected in a democracy the
weimar republic
and he was elected chancellor
he gets into power and the first thing
the nazis do is they burn down their own
capital called the reichstag
uh blame it on a dutch communist
and
uh pass a rep a
the reichstag fire act
to to criminalize dissent which is what
the democrats have been doing ever since
donald trump was elected criminalized
dissent
and establish the third reich
if you know one thing that my book the
enemy within does is i document
if you look at the
democrats agenda it's not about getting
rid of trump it's not about winning an
election it's about establishing a
one-party state
stack the supreme court that's to
abolish the independent judiciary
uh abolish the electoral college which
was designed to force presidential
candidates to compete in battleground
states where they didn't have a majority
let's force them to compromise our whole
system
is built on compromise that that's why
we've only had one civil war and no
successful coup d'etats
the democrat
program is a fascist program there is no
nobody the only republicans who are
legitimate
aren't those
uh you know like liz james right they
love they love liz cheney now because
she's a pet so so you you lay all of
this out in the book it's quite
extraordinary actually and as i said
you've been right about a lot of stuff
way before
a lot of people so what do you think the
average conservative and i now use that
term in a broad sense if you believe
america is good you're a conservative as
far as i'm concerned what do you think
the average conservative can do to fight
this because it feels like the deck is
completely stacked against us well
republican conservatives have been
asleep for 50 years while the democrats
have taken over our culture i wrote five
books on the universities that
one of them people paid a little
attention to but the republican brand i
organized academic freedom campaigns
and i got no real support out of the
republican
party
but a bomb between obama and
i call them the alzheimer puppet
and by
one of the nastiest human beings on the
planet i don't know how he gets his
reputation for being a nice guy
they've begun to wake people up and
donald trump has given our country and
patriots a great gift
and that is he has created the first
mass conservative movement in our
history
when i came into the right in the
mid-80s
40 years ago now
looked around and said where's the
ground army
all my ex-comrades on the left are in or
they had a hundred organizations or 200
to harass and threaten
and defame politicians until they got on
their into their program and
corporations
are corporations
involved you know corporations are
basically cowards they don't want to
lose customers that's their
bottom line but if you harass them
enough
um
they will respond and it's interesting
already the backlash has caused them uh
disney just pulled back its
racist progress right
um
i long to see
people get in the face of teachers of
principals of superintendents of schools
of school boards
who are indoctrinating their children
and hate america garbage
and you know
we're so backward i was watching fox
and they're talking about the 1619
project
and they're talking about the 20 slaves
they weren't slaves i mean i've read
nell painter who was a black leftist
princeton historian on this subject
there were indentured servants
and slavery was actually outlawed in
virginia in 1619
and virginia was in america in 1619
it was a british colony and this is
supposed to be our founding according to
these liars
and yet
you know if you look at fox they're not
saying
they don't know the facts right to be
clear we were not a nation until about
150 years later so the idea that the
nation was founded on something that
happened 150 years before when everyone
was dead
uh seemed a little odd
exactly it's just terrible so
so what does the future is people i want
to see a sit-in at the headquarters of
twitter that don't see their censorship
embarrassing them
that's what's really needed and i i see
the the stirrings of it all over the
place there are people organized
particularly in the schools and that
that gives me hope
yeah do you think though that since you
brought up twitter that the big tech
part of this
is the part that makes the asymmetry so
out of whack it would be one thing if it
was slightly out of whack but now the
way we get information is so tilted that
people can't coordinate properly or
can't even get the information properly
or agree on what's true
change is coming
the one thing about tech is it's always
changing
um
and
what's it called sub stack already is a
media outlet it has a lot of people who
are
second orders like you um on it
uh people with impeccable leftist
credentials who are really upset about
the canceled cults and just the terms we
use
cancel culture it's book burning it's
what the nazis did in the 30s you can't
burn just burn books today because you
got a digital universe that you can't
but that's what it is
i would like to see people i mean i know
that i'm not making myself popular by
referring to the blind administration as
fascist
but technically that's what it is
and i tell you if we don't stop them
they will put us in re-education camps
they've already telegraphed that that
conservatives are yahoo racists who have
to be reprogrammed you think do we get
to share a gulag as the why i left the
left guys that would be nice
that's very probable
very
archipelago uh
and that book really moved me at the
time yeah well you know i toured with
jordan peterson and he often brought up
the gulag archipelago for the same
reason
always
thank my lucky stars for jordan peterson
otherwise i'd be feeling guilty about
all the things i wasn't writing
um
so
i would like to mention is the chapter
on
chapters on the blacklist
it's very very serious i'm not going to
name the outlet but i i wrote this
article
about how juan radar should
join the fascist and slip the knife
between my ribs i've i've got i've got
the piece right here yeah okay i play
i tried to place it
with a concer
very prominent conservative
media site but they they're also on
facebook
you know if you're a big media site you
got to be on all the platforms
and they said that
would
facebook would shut
we'll just close it down if it appeared
there
people have to understand we are in the
early stages of a fascist state we do
not america is no longer a free country
it's freedom is hard won by courageous
people like yourself
who are willing to stand up and take the
slings and arrows
so what what do we do then i mean okay
so we can sit in a twitter i mean i know
you're you're a fighter you've been
doing this for a long time i mean what
what do we really do like where so is
trump the only thing that can save us do
we need the return of trump to lead the
republicans like it ain't going to be
liz cheney
here's what i think about trump
you know people are talking about ron
desantis who might admire and in my
blacklist story i tell how they used
first
you know they called me a notorious
racist then because he spoke at my
events they
used that
and when i say day i'm talking about the
so-called liberal media new magazine
washington post use that to try to
taint him
and and destroy him
and he has a delivery which a lot of
people think is
you know
more user-friendly shall we say than
trump's
um
and i hope he's on the ticket actually
but the reason
that i believe that trump
is bound to be the leader
is
[Laughter]
he got 75 million votes despite four
years of unbelievable slander and lies
directed him and no credit from what
what he had done
but i think ordinary americans patriotic
americans see this guy
and someone here he was a billionaire
living the life
and he put himself and his family
through all this
to save the country basically
and i mean those credentials are
golden you you really can't beat them
and i think his aggression is necessary
the reason the democrats hate him is
because he called them out and you know
called them out as racist for their
control of the inner cities
um
called about for their betrayal and you
know i will say as somebody who's been
in politics
50 60 years
i had no idea that they were selling us
out in trade deals the way they
i mean it's it's bush
uh it's uh
you know bush clinton
um obama either they were too lazy
to cut decent deals for americans or
they just didn't care about fleecing our
country
for chinese communists they're genocidal
dictators for crying out tears well do
you think do you think that that's what
it really is that in many ways just
we've gone through several generations
at this point or at least several
decades of just leadership and an
institutional elite that has sold us out
at every level so there almost isn't
enough of what is american left to
defend the documents that freed all of
us
yeah you've got we have to have a leader
who fights and
that's trump
yeah what american would blow up the
southern border in the middle of a
global pandemic with new viruses or
variations variants as they call them
appearing all the time
binders just let a hundred thousand
covet carriers into the country
which shows what a liar is that time
he's accused trump of killing
coronavirus patients
he's
he's killing them he's killing americans
the child abuse is epic on the border
it's uh it's just unreal and the denial
of reality
you know this is what had you know this
is the norm it's not the norm
it's like 20 times whatever i forget the
actual statistics
but they're humongous in terms of the
deterioration
of the country the amount of criminals
who are being led in the amount of
people
who have not pledged allegiance to our
society america's unique
you know it's our culture something left
us never understand
culture
determines things how is it that japan
which has no natural resources
is a first world country
mexico which has oil which you know
always has had its independence for 100
years or whatever
you know is is
flooding
refugees into america what's the
difference between japan and mexico
[Music]
it's all about culture and america had a
great culture which is being
systematically
dismantled
by the democrats
just so as someone so as someone that
that gets this and as i said you've been
right on so much of this way earlier but
you're still now at you're losing
friends that are you know that you've
had for for 70 years
what do you think there people always
ask me this maybe you have a better
answer than i have
if someone's kind of wavering right now
and they're kind of waking up to some of
this stuff because i think a lot of
people are i think people are shocked at
how horrific the administration has been
and how out of control woke-ism is
do you have uh
what's what's the move that you've made
to really help people wake up
beyond just handing them facts i mean
that we know that that you know doesn't
work
yeah i
i mean this book has a lot about the
race issue and uh you know the way they
deploy racism and sexism as weapons
um i think the biggest thing
uh is
if some somebody is truly in transition
it means they're
reading and thinking or listening and
thinking
when i you know my friend our former
friend radash
it's been three years i could not ever
get him i would write an email and we
had all kinds of ground rules to protect
our egos or what have you
um
couldn't get him to consider a single
argument i said in my book on trump
blitz
i i said in the
manuscript of this book the enemy within
and in the article that he and stern
wrote for the new republic
there's not a single argument that i
give that's you know engaged
you're really trying to get me booted
from youtube huh
you know if i like i try to think about
those things i try never to get people
into situations
that they can't handle but i know that
you can handle it
and i i
can't thanks david
i can't clip my wings i heard i don't
bring you on to clip your wings
and i'll deal with those guys everything
rests
on creating or energizing this mass
movement and directing it to protest
this taking back the congress
dealing with the tech companies
you know
i mean trump was in power for four years
it's like republicans there for a decade
they said they're going to
repeal and replace obamacare and they
never did
that's the huge problem you know
conservatives are always complaining
about the media which is fair it's a
lying
disgusting media i'm racist about you
know seeing cnn they're just filled with
liars and racists
and not to mention msnbc
but the real problem is the politeness
of conservatives
you know conservatives are being called
white supremacists white nationalists
traitors enemies of the state
insurrectionists actually
and what do republicans call democrats
liberals
[Laughter]
you can't win that war we're the only
liberals
the only people in this country who want
to hear two sides to a
conversation are conservatives and you
know that
all you have to do is turn on fox or
newsmax
conservative media they're always
entertaining the other side because i
think conservatives are confident we can
win the arguments we're not afraid of
them and if we're wrong we're capable of
changing our views on the subject david
defending my liberal beliefs has become
a conservative position listen it's
always a pleasure talking to you because
i i love the fact that people people did
this before me and people will do this
after me and i appreciate all all the
fight and i you fled california so you
left me here uh so i hope to see you one
of these days but i'm guessing it's not
because you're coming back here
no you'll be on your way to florida or
some other
texas and you can stop on the way and
visit me the book the book is enemy
within thank you so much david
we'll see each other again on your
podcast because i got another book
coming out in the fall naturally i will
gladly have you on thank you my friend
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell